You might have watched the intro video for this class,
where I quoted the American super computer designer, Seymour Cray.
"If you were plowing a field, which would you rather use? Two strong oxen or 1024 chickens?"
Well, I love the chickens, and Dave loves the chickens,
and I hope by the end of this class you'll love the chickens too.
Now, the biggest idea in this course is parallelism.
We can solve large problems by breaking them up into smaller pieces.
Then we can run these smaller pieces at the same time.
Parallel computing used to be a niche technology used by exotic supercomputers.
Today, the world has gone parallel.
Modern computing products are like the chickens.
They have hundreds of processors that can each run a piece of your problem in parallel.
A high end GPU contains over 3,000 arithmetic units, ALUs,
that can simultaneously run 3,000 arithmetic operations.
GPUs can have tens of thousands of parallel pieces of work all active at the same time.
We call each of those pieces of work a thread,
and a modern GPU may be running up to 65,000 concurrent threads.
Together, all this computing power has the potential to help you
solve your problems faster than you ever could before.
But harnessing all that computing power at the same time, in parallel,
requires a different way of thinking than programming a single scalar processor,
where you're only doing one thing at a time.
In this class we'll teach you how to program the GPU,
allowing you to practice what we call GPU computing or GPGPU,
standing for general purpose programmability on the graphics processing unit.
More importantly, we'll teach you how to think about programming through a parallel lens.
The homework assignments in this class will center around image processing applications.
Frankly, they're pretty cool assignments,
and with them you'll be able to do some interesting visual effects at blazing fast speeds.